hey everyone thought I would share a
thought in these strange times hair and
beard both getting long haven't figured
out how to cut my hair yet might take
out the old razor and buzz it anyway
one of the things which I preach is
everybody knows is about being
optimistic this is different from being
positive and it's definitely not naive a
lot of people think that optimism is
naive it's not optimism is not the
denial of reality and positivity is
about saying things are good
even when they're not so like
everything's fine here nothing to see
here everything's good everything's good
we're good that's positivity we don't
need positivity right now optimism is
the belief that the future is positive
we are going through a hard time now
times are tough they're rough they're
dark but we will get through this
together
that's what optimism sounds like it is
not the denial of what is it is not
pretending that things aren't good is
simply the fundamental belief that
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
and we were heading towards that light
so be optimistic we will get through
this together take care of yourself take
care of others talk to you soon
[Music]